j'ai dit bonjour vous êtes notre
correspondante à Washington la Maison
Blanche Gauthier évoquée à l'instant à
cette promesse de livraison Dharma à
l'Ukraine par par les Américains je vais
annoncer la livraison d'autres
équipements essentiels notamment des
munitions d'artillerie des systèmes
antiblindage et des radars de
surveillance aériennes à indiquer Joe
Biden selon communiqué donc de la Maison
Blanche qui en dit plus maintenant
oui alors on a reçu un email en effet de
la Maison Blanche qui nous a indiqué
bien que Joe Biden était arrivé donc à
Kiev à 8h du matin heure locale pour
cette visite surprise les journalistes
qui l'accompagnaient et qui ont été
prévenus au dernier moment ont dû
évidemment remettre tout leurs appareils
électroniques leur téléphone leur
portable au service secret pour essayer
que le cette visite soit tenue la plus
secrète possible alors la rumeur courait
depuis un certain temps que si Joe Biden
se rendait en Pologne et bien il allait
tenter de se rendre en
Ukraine il voulait déjà le faire lors de
son de sa première visite en Pologne il
y a quelques mois mais les services de
sécurité l'en avait dissuadé pour Joe
Biden c'était vraiment important de de
faire cette visite très symbolique pour
montrer le soutien des États-Unis à
l'Ukraine il a notamment déclaré aux
côtés du président zellenski qu'il était
très important qu'il n'y ait aucun doute
sur le soutien de Washington à Kiev il a
aussi fait donc cette annonce d'une
nouvelle livraison d'armement
supplémentaires à l'Ukraine d'un montant
de 500 millions de dollars il a aussi
évidemment salué la résistance
ukrainienne il a déclaré un an plus tard
là un an plus tard Kiev un an plus tard
qui a brésiste l'Ukraine résiste la
démocratie résiste pour Biden donc cette
visite est très symbolique et ce conflit
en général est très symbolique parce que
pendant sa campagne électorale et bien
Joe Biden a plusieurs fois insister sur
l'importance de de lutter contre les
régimes autoritaires et donc ce conflit
en est un exemple pour les États-Unis il
est très important de soutenir l'Ukraine
pour soutenir les la démocratie face au
régime autoritaire et puis pour Joe
Biden enfin en faisant cette visite il
vient rappeler au public américain
l'enjeu de ce conflit alors que le
soutien de la population américaine
envers l'Ukraine s'effrite justement un
mot de l'opinion publique américaine
vis-à-vis de cette guerre le président
américain va donc demain en détailler
cette nouvelle tranche d'aide de 500
millions de dollars à l'Ukraine un coup
de pouce supplémentaire est-ce que les
Américains suivent toujours Joe Biden
sur ce point et bien selon les derniers
sondages les
pourcentage d'un Américain qui soutient
l'envoi d'armes à l'Ukraine à diminué
depuis par exemple le mois de mars juste
après le début du conflit donc
clairement les le soutien des Américains
pour continuer d'aider d'envoyer des
armes à l'Ukraine diminue il y a
toujours un une un soutien en général
dans la population pour les Ukrainiens
mais c'est vrai que alors que
l'inflation est encore forte que les
Américains connaissent des difficultés
économiques il va être et Joe Biden le
sait de plus en plus difficile facile
avec le temps de convaincre les
Américains de d'envoyer toujours autant
d'armes et encore plus d'armes aux
Ukrainiens et puis évidemment au Congrès
il y a un groupe de républicains ils ne
sont pas majoritaires mais il y a un
groupe de républicains qui a fait passer
qui tente de faire passer une résolution
pour qui s'appelle la fatigue autour de
du conflit en Ukraine pour dire qu'il
faut arrêter de de consacrer autant de
du budget de l'État à ce conflit en
Ukraine un dernier mot Sonia peut-être
Joe Biden à Kiev aujourd'hui et demain
en Pologne Anthony blinken aujourd'hui à
Ankara où il rencontrait ce matin
raychep taille perdwan le chef de la
diplomatie américaine on n'est pas passé
à côté amusant garde hier sur le le
soutien des des chinois aux Russes la
Chine qui selon lui va livrer des armes
Horus pour leur apporter là aussi un
soutien logistique ce que Pékin a
démenti ce matin cette visite elle
intervient sur fond aussi de de tension
croissante entre Washington et E Pékin
oui et c'est vrai que le pour le la
Maison Blanche est vraiment une
difficulté cette relation avec Pékin
autant la Maison Blanche souvent mais en
avant le fait qu'elle a vraiment réussi
à à unir les alliés européens dans ce
conflit
contre la Russie entre entre l'Ukraine
et la Russie mais il y a une difficulté
évidemment avec la Chine parce que
le soutien de de malgré les témanties la
Maison Blanche pointe du doigt le
soutien de la Chine à à la Russie et il
y a eu cette tentative il y a environ
deux semaines d'un apaisement avec Pékin
d'ailleurs le secrétaire Anthony blinken
devait se rendre à Pékin en pour tenter
d'apaiser les relations et évidemment
tenter de de rallier la Chine en tout
cas de convaincre la Chine de ne pas
aider la Russie et puis il y a eu cette
affaire du ballon espion chinois qui a
finalement le secrétaire d'État
américain est bien à le finalement le
secrétaire d'État américain a dû annuler
son voyage en Chine et donc évidemment
c'est une difficulté pour les États-Unis
merci beaucoup c'est en direct de
Washington pour